Malaysians woke up to an uncertain
future on Sunday with no clear winner in
the general election negotiations have
begun to determine who will join forces
to make up the majority in Parliament
opposition blocked the alliance of Hope
led by Anwar Ibrahim has the most seats
but not enough
or National Alliance is the second
largest coalition
it's met with leaders of a regional
party based in Sarawak State who now has
the potential to be king maker
I am quite unsettled because now the
alliance of Hope and pericature National
are going neck and neck I am hoping for
the best for the new government I just
hope that they are all United because in
the end it's really about the country
it's for the people and it's for the
future some analysts say it's possible
the same parties that were in power
before Parliament was dissolved could
work together again which may upset some
voters as this Alliance would include
barisa National or the national front
whose leaders are tainted by corruption
the most important thing is for
pre-cater National to only choose or
appoint candidates or
parliamentarians that don't have any
issues with corruption there are plenty
of those and they can be part of the
government and the second part of it is
that Regatta National will have to
remain convicted on dedicate the
dedication towards Prosecuting those
with corruption charges One winner in
this election is the Malaysian Islamic
party a partner in the National Alliance
it's now the largest party in Parliament
by Monday afternoon Malaysians should
know who their new prime minister will
be the palace has issued a statement
asking leaders of the political parties
with the most seats and heads of the
major coalitions to nominate a lawmaker
who they think is able to command the
confidence of the majority in Parliament
King Al Sultan Abdullah has had a hand
in determining the Prime Minister before
in 2020 after interviewing MPS the
Monarch chose muyidin Yasin and when his
administration collapsed a year later
the king chose a successor history it
seems could repeat itself
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur